This is 99% indiscible. I'm Roman Mars. The City of Toronto has a special relationship with raccoons, or at least, they think they do. We're not the only city with raccoons, but we often act like we are. We like to think Toronto is the raccoon capital of the world. And we're strangely proud of that distinction, but we really have no data to back it up. This is Amy Dempsey, a reporter for the Toronto Star. Do we have more raccoons than say Chicago or Vancouver? Well, we don't actually know. You can't count urban raccoons.
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。多伦多市与浣熊有着一种特殊的渊源，或者说，他们自己是这么认为的。我们并不是唯一有浣熊的城市，但我们常常表现得好像只有我们有一样。我们总喜欢认为多伦多是世界的浣熊之都。而且我们对这个称号感到一种奇怪的自豪，但我们实际上没有任何数据来支撑这一点。这是《多伦多星报》（Toronto Star）的记者艾米·邓普西（Amy Dempsey）。我们的浣熊比芝加哥或温哥华多吗？嗯，我们其实并不知道。你没法去统计城市里的浣熊。
They're all over the place. But who needs data when you can feel it in your heart? A few years ago when a raccoon died on Young Street, Torontonians named him Conrad and built a vigil around his body with flowers and a framed photo and cards. So if science ever disproves this idea of Toronto as raccoon nation, I really fear for Toronto. I think we're going to have an identity crisis.
它们到处都是。但当你能在心中感受到这一点时，谁还需要数据呢？几年前，当一只浣熊在央街（Yonge Street）丧命时，多伦多市民给它取名叫康拉德（Conrad），并在它的尸体周围举行了烛光守夜，摆上了鲜花、带框的照片和卡片。所以，如果科学有朝一日推翻了多伦多是浣熊之国的这种想法，我真的会为多伦多感到担忧。我觉得我们要面临身份认同危机了。
But Toronto's feelings about raccoons are not uncomficated. Our relationship with raccoons is kind of a love-hate relationship. We hate when they destroy our grass and break into our houses. And yes, they do break into our houses. Maybe worse than all this though, was the raccoons' proclivity for getting into the compost, which the city started collecting for the residents in green bins several years ago. From the perspective of the raccoons, these compost bins were an incredible development
但多伦多对浣熊的感情并非那么简单。我们与浣熊的关系有点像是爱恨交织。我们讨厌它们破坏草坪、闯入我们的民宅。没错，它们确实会闯入我们的民宅。不过，比这更糟糕的可能是浣熊对翻找厨余垃圾的狂热，几年前，市政府开始用绿色垃圾桶为居民收集这些垃圾。在浣熊看来，这些厨余垃圾桶简直是一项了不起的发明
and all you can eat buffet with the plastic and other garbage already thoughtfully removed. And the raccoons would go to town on our stuff and just spread it everywhere. And you'd wake up, look out your window and go, shit! And then maybe you'd argue with your spouse or roommates about who'd have to clean it up. The green bins become a feast, a veritable feast for the raccoons. This is Toronto Mayor John Tory.
而且是一个全食自助餐，塑料和其他垃圾都已经被人体贴地清理掉了。浣熊会在我们的东西里大肆搜刮，把它们弄得到处都是。你一觉醒来，往窗外一看，心想：靠！然后你可能会跟伴侣或室友争论到底该轮到谁去打扫。绿色垃圾桶变成了一场盛宴，对浣熊来说简直是一场真正的饕餮盛宴。这是多伦多市长庄德利（John Tory）。
After years ago, dressed in a blue suit in front of a row of Canadian flags. This is if he's announcing a plan to step up the war on crime. And in a way, he was. There's probably nothing that represents more of a nuisance in a big city like this than the feasting of the raccoons on the contents of the green bins. The war on raccoons sort of started with Mayor John Tory. We've discovered that the members of raccoons nation are smart,
四年前，他身穿一套蓝色西装，站在一排加拿大国旗下。这架势就像是要宣布一项加大打击犯罪力度的计划。从某种程度上讲，他也确实这么做了。在大城市里，可能没有什么比浣熊在绿色垃圾桶里大吃大喝更让人头疼的烦心事了。打击浣熊的战争某种程度上就是从庄德利市长开始的。我们发现浣熊国的人民很聪明，
they're hungry, and they're determined. But our job, together with our private sector reinforcements, is to show them that we are smarter. He said things like, we are ready, we are armed, we are motivated. We have left no stone unturned in our fight against Raccoon Nation. The reason Mayor Tory felt so prepared that day was that the city was unveiling a new raccoon-resistant green bin for organic waste. During the same press conference, the mayor held up the new bin victoriously and handed up with reporters as cameras flashed.
它们很饥饿，而且意志坚定。但我们的工作，加上我们私营部门的增援部队，就是要向它们证明我们更聪明。他说过这样的话：“我们已经准备好了，我们全副武装，斗志昂扬。我们在对抗浣熊国的战斗中已经用尽了一切手段。”庄德利市长之所以那天感觉准备如此充分，是因为市政府正在展示一款全新的、防浣熊的绿色有机垃圾桶。在同一次新闻发布会上，市长胜利地举起了新垃圾桶，在闪光灯下与记者们互动。
I would say it was 75% tongue-in-cheek, but there was also a hint of seriousness to it. It was pretty clear that he was confident the new green bins would solve our raccoon problems, confident enough to stand in front of news cameras and say, you know, defeat is not an option. But Amy was about to find out for herself whether defeat was an option and spoiler alert. It was an option and spoiler alert. It was an option. Let's back up just a bit. This all started the way most things start in cities with an RFP.PDF.
我想这其中有75%是在开玩笑，但也有那么一丝认真。很明显，他坚信新的绿色垃圾桶能解决我们的浣熊问题，自信到足以站在新闻摄像机前说：“你知道，认输不是选项。”但艾米很快就要亲自验证认输是不是一个选项了，剧透警告：这就是个选项。剧透警告：这就是个选项。让我们稍微倒回一点。这一切的开始和城市里大多数事情的开始一样，都是从一份求标书（RFP）PDF开始的。
Yeah, they put out a request for proposals asking for a new generation green bin and emphasizing that it had to be rodent resistant, a K.A. Animal resistant, a K.A. Raccoon proof, please. The company that one was called Rarig Pacific. I'm Dennis Monestier with Rarig Pacific, and I serve as the Environmental Sales Manager for Canada. If the City of Toronto wasn't a war with raccoons, this ladies and gentlemen was the general in charge of a major front and he took his role very seriously. I mean, Rereg Pacific takes new product development very, very seriously and there's a five-pronged approach which we initiate. Dennis is in many ways a classic sales guy.
对，他们发布了一份征求建议书，要求设计新一代的绿色垃圾桶，并强调它必须防啮齿动物，也就是防动物，也就是防浣熊，拜托了。中标的公司叫拉里格太平洋公司（Raric Pacific）。我是拉里格太平洋公司的丹尼斯·莫内斯蒂尔（Dennis Monestier），我担任加拿大地区的环保销售经理。如果多伦多市是在跟浣熊打仗，那女士们先生们，这位就是负责某个主要前线的将军，他非常认真地对待自己的角色。我的意思是，拉里格太平洋公司对新产品开发非常非常严肃，我们有一套包含五个步骤的流程。丹尼斯在很多方面都是个典型的销售人员。
He wears shirts with his company logo. He has a firm handshake. I found him to be extremely helpful and genuine. And when he speaks about the green bin, you can tell he's really proud of it. It's something that I'm very, very passionate about, not only being part of the design team, but I'm also a resident in the city of Toronto.
他穿着印有公司标志的衬衫。他的握手很有力。我发现他非常乐于助人且真诚。当他谈到这个绿色垃圾桶时，你能看出他是真的为之自豪。这是我非常非常热爱的事业，不仅因为我是设计团队的一员，而且我也是多伦多的居民。
So I know what it means to me as a resident. Rareg Pacific had a number of design criteria they were trying to meet with their green Ben prototype. For example, the Benz would need to be picked up and dumped by an automatic arm that reached out from the truck. So the bin would need a lid that closed and locked to protecting its raccoons, but the lid would also have to open up automatically when the bin was turned upside down and dumped into the truck by the arm. So we had to ensure that the lock itself
所以我很清楚它对我这个居民意味着什么。拉里格太平洋公司在设计绿色垃圾桶原型时，有一系列他们试图满足的设计标准。例如，垃圾桶需要能够被卡车伸出的自动机械臂提起并倾倒。因此，垃圾桶需要一个能关闭并锁上的盖子来防范浣熊，但当垃圾桶被机械臂倒过来倾倒到卡车里时，盖子也必须自动打开。所以我们必须确保锁本身
disengages 100% of the time. The container must function in extreme weather conditions, ergonomics, easily open with one single hand. We are looking at, you know, safety. Kids end up in the darned places. Definitely don't want them in an organic container, but more importantly, we don't want them locked inside the container. The elimination of internal catch points, any material that becomes trapped inside the container could pose significant risk with respect to the Ick factor for the residents. But on top of the Ick factor and the meddling kids, rare Pacific had to think about enemy number
在100%的情况下都能解锁。容器必须能在极端天气下使用，符合人体工程学，单手即可轻松打开。我们要考虑的是安全问题。小孩子们总是会跑到奇奇怪怪的地方去。绝对不希望他们被关在有机垃圾容器里，但更重要的是，我们不希望他们被锁在容器里面。消除内部的卡点，任何被困在容器内部的材料都可能给居民带来巨大的恶心感风险。但除了恶心感和调皮的小孩，拉里格太平洋公司还必须考虑头号敌人
one, the raccoons. Yeah, so we worked with an urban raccoon specialist to basically understand We worked with an urban raccoon specialist to basically understand raccoons' likes, dislikes, their dexterity, what they can and cannot do. It was a local raccoon specialist by the name of Suzanne McDonald. I'm Dr. Suzanne McDonald. I'm a professor at York University. I study animal behavior. Calling her a raccoon specialist really downplays her accomplishments. She is a professor of biology and psychology who has studied just about every animal you can think of. She may have studied every animal you can think of, but in Toronto, there's only one animal that matters. In Toronto, everybody talks about raccoons. I work in Vancouver a lot and nobody talks about raccoons. There's raccoons all the time.
——浣熊。对，所以我们跟一位城市浣熊专家合作，基本上是为了了解我们跟一位城市浣熊专家合作，了解浣熊的喜好、厌恶、它们的灵巧程度，以及它们能做什么和不能做什么。这位当地的浣熊专家名叫苏珊·麦克唐纳（Suzanne McDonald）。我是苏珊·麦克唐纳博士。我是约克大学（York University）的教授。我研究动物行为。叫她浣熊专家真的太低估她的成就了。她是一位生物学和心理学教授，研究过你能想到的几乎所有动物。她可能研究过你能想到的所有动物，但在多伦多，只有一个动物是重要的。在多伦多，每个人都在谈论浣熊。我在温哥华呆的时间很多，没人谈论浣熊。那里一直都有浣熊。
So she wasn't that surprised when Rare Pacific got in touch as they were designing their bin. And they asked me to talk to them about how raccoons work and I did. Well, raccoons are omnivores, so that means they can eat everything. They're mischievous. Raccoons have really good teeth, they'll use them.
所以当拉里格太平洋公司在设计垃圾桶时联系她时，她并没有感到太意外。他们请我跟他们谈谈浣熊是如何运作的，我就照做了。嗯，浣熊是杂食动物，这意味着它们什么都吃。它们很淘气。浣熊的牙齿非常好，它们会用的。
They don't want to use them. They want you to go away. You go away. You're in my yard. They also get a taste for human food. So once they get a taste for that Indian takeout that we've thrown out that they've enjoyed, from then on, it's like berries. I'm not eating berries.
它们其实不想用。它们只想让你走开。你走开。你在我的院子里。它们对人类的食物也很感兴趣。所以一旦它们尝过我们扔掉的、它们觉得很好吃的印度外卖，从那以后，这就跟浆果一样了。我才不吃浆果呢。
We look at them, they look at us. If you would look at a monkey in the face, they look away. But raccoons don't, they look right at us. They look right through us. You know, they have pretty good senses of smell, they have pretty good vision, but touch is their superpower. They're very persistent. They will work at a problem for hours and hours and hours, and they're pretty strong.
我们看着它们，它们看着我们。如果你直视一只猴子的脸，它们会移开视线。但浣熊不会，它们直勾勾地看着我们。它们仿佛看穿了我们。你知道，它们的嗅觉相当灵敏，视力也很好，但触觉才是它们的超能力。它们非常执着。它们会针对一个问题琢磨几个小时又几个小时，而且它们力气挺大。
Raric Pacific took all of this information and applied it to their bin design. There was multiple iterations of the design. There's multiple photo-realistic renderings. In the end, they came out with a bin they believed in. It's an olive green 26-gallon container with a lid that closes and locks. We felt very, very confident with the success of that locking mechanism and the container itself. So the new green bin rollout took about 18 months from start to finish. People are waiting for their new green bins and people are getting really excited about these things.
拉里格太平洋公司吸收了所有这些信息，并将其应用到垃圾桶的设计中。设计经历了多次迭代。有多个逼真的渲染图。最后，他们推出了一个他们深信不疑的垃圾桶。这是一个橄榄绿色的26加仑容器，配有一个可以关闭并锁上的盖子。我们对该锁定机制和容器本身的成功感到非常非常有信心。因此，新绿色垃圾桶的推广从头到尾大约花了18个月。人们在等待他们的新绿色垃圾桶，大家对这些东西感到非常兴奋。
Before they were rolled out on my street, they were rolled out on some of the streets nearby. So people on my street would have to walk by and see that Holmes near us had the new green bin and we didn't. And you'd sort of be thinking on your walk to the subway to go to work like, the hell, where where's my bin? But eventually Amy did get a bin of her own. So on the, there is a dial, like a handle that you turn. And when it's in the horizontal position, it's open. When it's in the vertical position, it's secured. It's locked. You actually have to turn it in a way that really would make it difficult if not impossible to turn if you don't have opposable thumbs.
在它们被推广到我的街道之前，它们已经在附近的一些街道上推广了。所以我这条街的人走过时，会看到我们附近的房子有了新的绿色垃圾桶，而我们没有。当你走去地铁站上班时，你心里可能会想：搞什么鬼，我的垃圾桶呢？但最终艾米确实得到了自己的垃圾桶。所以在上面，有一个转盘，就像一个你可以转动的把手。当它处于水平位置时，它是打开的。当它处于垂直位置时，它是锁定的。它是安全的。你必须以一种真正的方式转动它，如果你没有对立的拇指，转动它会变得很困难，甚至不可能。
In contrary to popular belief, raccoons don't have opposable thumbs, even though they can move the thumb-like digit on their creepy little hands a little bit. In any case, for a while, everything seemed to be going according to plan. In fact, some people were worried that the new bins were working too well. In other words, people were afraid that without the green bins as a food source, maybe the raccoons were starving. So the way I became involved in all of this was that in January of 2018, a friend sent me a note saying that he believed the new green bins had eliminated the raccoon population in
与流行看法相反，浣熊没有对立的拇指，尽管它们可以用它们那毛骨悚然的小手上类似拇指的指头稍微活动一下。无论如何，有一段时间，一切似乎都按计划进行。事实上，有些人担心新垃圾桶的效果太好了。换句话说，人们担心如果没有绿色垃圾桶作为食物来源，浣熊可能会挨饿。我卷入这一切的经过是这样的：2018年1月，一个朋友给我发了一条便条，说他相信新的绿色垃圾桶已经消灭了
Toronto. He actually used the word eliminated. As any intrepid reporter would do, Amy decided to look into it. I wrote a quick email to Suzanne McDonald, our local raccoon expert, and I said, hey, could the raccoons be dying? She just said, eh, they're probably hiding from the cold. But she said she would have more information in a few months.
多伦多的浣熊数量。他甚至用了“消灭”这个词。作为一个有进取心的记者，艾米决定对此进行调查。我给我们的本地浣熊专家苏珊·麦克唐纳写了一封简短的电子邮件，我说，嘿，浣熊会死掉吗？她只是说，呃，它们可能是在躲避严寒。但她说她会在几个月后掌握更多信息。
She said after I measure more dead raccoons. So I of course wrote back immediately and said, can I come? Animal control was collecting raccoons killed by cars and storing them in freezers for Suzanne, who would then come in and measure them in order to track the health of the population from year to year. And I do this four times a year. And when you go in July, it turns out,
她说，等我测量了更多死浣熊之后。所以我当然立刻回信说，我可以去吗？动物管制部门一直在收集被汽车撞死的浣熊，并将它们存在冰箱里留给苏珊，苏珊随后会去测量它们的尺寸，以便年复一年地追踪种群的健康状况。我一年做四次这个。结果证明，当你在七月去的时候，
and you bring out frozen raccoon carcasses, and it takes a while to measure them, they start to melt. Oh, dear God, you can imagine the maggots and the blood and all the things, but that's fine. I mean, this is science we push through. Suzanne wouldn't have the results of her data for a while, but while Amy was there watching her measure dead raccoons, she asked her.
你搬出冷冻的浣熊尸体，花上一段时间测量它们，它们就开始融化了。哦，天哪，你可以想象那些蛆虫、血迹和各种东西，但没关系。我的意思是，这就是科学，我们要挺过去。苏珊还要过一段时间才有数据结果，但当艾米在那里看着她测量死浣熊时，她问她。
Do you think it's possible they could learn how to get into the new green bins? And she shook her head, no. She said, you know, she'd filmed them trying and not one of them could do it. She just said, they won't get in. The raccoons won't break into these green bins. So he has a raccoon proof of green bin.
你觉得它们有没有可能学会如何打开新的绿色垃圾桶？她摇了摇头，说没有。她说，你知道的，她拍过它们尝试的视频，没有一只做得到。她只是说，它们进不去的。浣熊是无法闯入这些绿色垃圾桶的。所以他有一个防浣熊的绿色垃圾桶。
Toronto spent a lot of money on the raccoon proof green bins. And this was video that was put out yesterday. So I come back to the internet. Then about a week later, this story comes out. So look to your left. So watch us. I'll zoom into it here. Hold on.
多伦多在防浣熊绿色垃圾桶上花了很多钱。这是昨天发布的视频。所以我回到了互联网上。然后大约一周后，这个故事出来了。所以看你的左边。看我们。我在这里放大一下。等等。
It's basically a local Toronto resident who has filmed a video of a raccoon opening his green bin. Let's give that little tug. There we go. Now he's not going to get it. And just like kind of winking at the camera almost. Really? This was not the only report of a bend being broken into, although it was the first to
这基本上是多伦多当地居民拍摄的一段浣熊打开他的绿色垃圾桶的视频。让我们给它轻轻拉一下。这就对了。现在它弄不开了。而且就像是在对镜头眨眼一样。真的吗？这并不是唯一关于垃圾桶被撬开的报告，尽管它是第一个
include video which quickly went viral, much to the dismay of Dennis Monastery from Rarig Pacific. For somebody just to come out and say, oh, the container doesn't work, you know, is frustrating. The video's Dennis says, don't tell the whole story. A couple of break-ins doesn't mean, you know, is frustrating. The videos Dennis says don't tell the whole story. A couple of break ins doesn't mean the design is flawed. The screw might be loosened too much. And if you just simply tighten it a little bit,
包含视频的报告，该视频迅速在网上走红，这让拉里格太平洋公司的丹尼斯·莫内斯蒂尔感到非常沮丧。对于有人突然跳出来说，哦，这个容器不管用，你知道的，这让人很沮丧。丹尼斯说，视频并没有说明事情的全貌。几次破门并不意味着，你知道的，这让人很沮丧。丹尼斯说，视频并没有说明事情的全貌。几次撬锁并不意味着设计有缺陷。可能是螺丝拧得太松了。如果你稍微把它拧紧一点，
it might prevent the issue. Dennis is frustrated by the fact that sometimes when people have issues with their green bins, they don't call the city, they don't report their issues to 3-1-1. Instead, they sometimes call the local newspaper and then it becomes a story. I think he said something to me like, you know, when your car breaks down, you don't call the Toronto star.
也许就能解决这个问题。丹尼斯感到沮丧的是，有时人们在使用绿色垃圾桶遇到问题时，他们不给市政府打电话，也不向311报告问题。相反，他们有时会打电话给当地报纸，然后这就变成了一条新闻。我想他跟我说过类似这样的话：你知道，当你的车抛锚时，你不会打电话给《多伦多星报》。
You call the mechanic. I don't know. For some reason, you know, Toronto specifically, they love to glamorize raccoons. The city for its part blamed the handful of break-ins on user error. And the city's response was to suggest that these homeowners weren't locking their bins properly and to emphasize they had only had a handful of complaints at a 450,000 green bins. The suggestion being that if Joe in Yorkville had a problem with his bin?
你得给修理工打电话。我不知道。出于某种原因，你知道，多伦多的人特别喜欢把浣熊浪漫化。市政府则将零星的几起破门事件归咎于用户操作失误。市政府的回应是暗示这些房主没有正确锁好垃圾桶，并强调在45万个绿色垃圾桶中，他们只接到过寥寥数起投诉。这暗示的意思是，如果约克维尔（Yorkville）的乔对他的垃圾桶有意见？
Then maybe the problem was Joe and not the bin. So soon after, I woke up one morning and walked outside and saw that my neighbor's green bin was on the ground in our laneway and there was food everywhere. So I texted my neighbor and said, the raccoons have gotten into your green bin. She said, you know, what the hell can the raccoons get into the green bins now? At this point Amy had been convinced by the city's argument. There was no problem with the bins. The problem was the users. I wrote back and said, more likely that you didn't lock it properly.
那可能问题出在乔身上，而不是垃圾桶身上。不久之后，我一天早上醒来，走到外面，发现邻居的绿色垃圾桶倒在我们的小巷地上，到处都是食物。于是我给邻居发短信说，浣熊进你的绿色垃圾桶了。她说，你知道的，搞什么鬼，浣熊现在能打开绿色垃圾桶了吗？到了这个时候，艾米已经被市政府的论点说服了。垃圾桶没有问题。问题出在用户身上。我回信说，更有可能是你没把它锁好。
I still have the text message and when I read it, I cringe a little bit. It's like, no, I don't think you locked it properly, Caroline. But Amy didn't get to stay smug for long. Two nights later, her own bin was plundered. My husband and I get a group text message from Caroline. The raccoons have gotten into your green bin. At this point, I'm floored because my husband is a person who locks things and checks locks like seven times. It seemed the reporter had just become a character in her own story.
我手机里还留着那条短信，当我读到它时，我禁不住感到有点尴尬。就像是，不，卡洛琳，我觉得你没锁好。但艾米没能得意太久。两天后，她自己的垃圾桶也被洗劫了。我和丈夫收到了卡洛琳发来的群发短信。浣熊进你们的绿色垃圾桶了。听到这个消息我惊呆了，因为我丈夫是一个会锁东西并且把锁检查个七遍的人。看来这位记者刚刚成了自己故事里的一个角色。
I'm thinking like first of all, do they, like this is so weird, do they know that I was looking into this stuff, you know, and my being targeted. Amy called the city who said, man, please, you probably just have a broken handle. And they sent some workers out to fix it. And they replaced the lid on my bin as a precaution, even though they couldn't find anything wrong with it. She also wrote to the raccoon expert, Suzanne McDonald, who was thrilled because she's always secretly been on team raccoon. She wrote back almost immediately and said, that is awesome.
我心想，首先，它们会吗，这太奇怪了，它们知道我在调查这些事情吗，你知道的，我是不是被针对了。艾米打电话给市政府，市政府说，拜托，你大概只是把把手弄断了。他们派了一些工人来修理。作为预防措施，他们更换了我垃圾桶的盖子，尽管他们找不到任何毛病。她还写信给浣熊专家苏珊·麦克唐纳，苏珊听后欣喜若狂，因为她一直暗中站在浣熊阵营这边。她几乎立刻回信说，太棒了。
And she said, I'm going to loan you a trail camera, and you have to see how they're doing it. So I get the camera from Suzanne. We meet up at the zoo one day. I go to our local grocery store, and I get a couple of chickens. Put the chicken in the green bin rubbed some of the chicken grease all over the green bin. The first night raccoons did not come.
她说，我要借给你一个野生动物追踪相机，你得去看看它们是怎么做到的。于是我从苏珊那里拿到了相机。有一天我们在动物园碰面。我去当地的杂货店买了几只鸡。把鸡放进绿色垃圾桶里，还在绿色垃圾桶周围抹了一些鸡油。第一天晚上浣熊没有来。
The second night I went out to the front porch, actually, with my toddler. We peaked around the corner and my daughter said, Uh-oh! The bin was down, it was a mess. I took the camera upstairs, then pressed play on the video that I captured. It's almost as though the raccoons knew what I was doing and they were like, let's give her a really good shot here. This one is going to go viral.
第二天晚上我走到前廊，实际上是带着我蹒跚学步的孩子。我们绕过拐角偷看，我女儿说：“噢噢！”垃圾桶倒了，一片狼藉。我把相机拿上楼，然后按下播放键，播放我拍下的视频。这几乎就像浣熊知道我在做什么一样，它们好像在说：让我们给她拍个好镜头吧。这个视频要火了。
The camera is pointing at the bins and then all of a sudden this this mama raccoon comes skulking out and she just pulls the bin down like and she gets out of the way like at this point you can tell she knows what she's doing like she's not gonna stand in the way and get crushed by the bin no she's gonna pull it at the exact right angle and it just falls down with like a and turns round and looks at the camera as if to say, watch this. And then she turns the handle and just opens it. Like just turns it. You open it just like I would and then they go. The key seemed to be knocking down the bin, which made the handle much easier to turn.
相机正对准垃圾桶，突然这只母浣熊鬼鬼祟祟地钻了出来，它一把将垃圾桶拉倒，就像这样，然后闪到一边，在这个时候你能看出它知道自己在做什么，它不会站在原地被垃圾桶砸到，不，它会以精准的角度拉倒垃圾桶，垃圾桶“咚”的一声倒下，然后它转过身来看着镜头，仿佛在说：看这个。接着它转动把手，直接把它打开了。就像转动一下。你打开它就像我一样，然后它们就开始吃了。关键似乎是把垃圾桶撞倒，这使得把手更容易转动。
When it's on the ground, you can just kind of pull on it. Like as if you're pulling a lever, you know, you can almost bat your paws at it or like pull it to the side. On August 30th, 2018, Amy published an article in the Toronto Star with her video. And as these things tend to do in Toronto, it went viral.
当它躺在地上时，你可以直接拉它。就像拉一个杠杆一样，你知道的，你几乎可以用爪子拍打它，或者把它往旁边拉。2018年8月30日，艾米在《多伦多星报》上发表了一篇文章，并附上了她的视频。正如多伦多的这类事情一样，它火了。
Thousands of Torontonians watched as the protagonist handily pulled down the bin, and then flashing her glowing eyes at the camera, showed off how easily she could open it. Amy got a bunch of emails and comments on the article, people saying that this was happening to them too, but the city maintained they were getting relatively few complaints overall. When Amy told Dennis Monastery from Riric Pacific that the raccoons were getting into the bin that his company designed, he decided to pay her a house call. You know, I personally wanted to go out there myself to inspect the container and to do some torque force testing on the handle itself. Some heroes don't wear capes. They wear polo
成千上万的多伦多市民看着这位主角轻巧地拉倒垃圾桶，然后用它那发光的眼睛对着镜头闪烁，展示着它是多么容易地就能把它打开。艾米收到了许多关于这篇文章的电子邮件和评论，人们说这种事也发生在他身上，但市政府坚称他们总共收到的投诉相对较少。当艾米告诉拉里格太平洋公司的丹尼斯·莫内斯蒂尔浣熊正在钻进他公司设计的垃圾桶时，他决定亲自上门拜访。你知道的，我个人想亲自去实地检查容器，并对把手本身进行扭力测试。有些英雄不穿披风。他们穿着胸前口袋印有公司logo的Polo衫。
shirts with the company logo on the breast pocket. The day Dennis came over, my neighbor Mike came over as soon as he saw this guy in my driveway working on the green bin, but Mike had no idea that this is the green bin guy. It seemed like there was a gang of neighbors that came up all of a son out of nowhere. And it was just like, oh, we have, you know, we have some problems with the raccoons getting into our bins. Getting in my bin, they're getting in everybody's bin, and he's just ripping on the green bins and the waste of money.
丹尼斯来的那天，我的邻居迈克一看到这个家伙在我的车道上鼓捣绿色垃圾桶就过来了，但迈克根本不知道这就是绿色垃圾桶先生。感觉就像有一帮邻居不知从哪里突然冒出来。那种感觉就像是，哦，我们知道，我们对浣熊钻进我们的垃圾桶有一些意见。钻进我的垃圾桶，它们钻进每个人的垃圾桶，而他就在那里猛烈抨击绿色垃圾桶和这种浪费钱的行为。
Dennis took it all like a champ. He tightened up everyone's handles so they'd be particularly hard for a little raccoon pause to turn. But it hasn't solved the problem. Having accepted defeat, Amy now keeps her bins tied to a wall so raccoons can't knock them over. And she can't help but wonder how soon before this knowledge about how to open the bin spreads to the rest of Raccoon Nation.
丹尼斯像个男子汉一样坦然接受了这一切。他把每个人的把手都拧紧了，这样小浣熊的爪子就很难转动它们了。但这并没有解决问题。在接受了失败之后，艾米现在把她的垃圾桶绑在墙上，这样浣熊就推不倒它们了。她不禁想知道，这种关于如何打开垃圾桶的知识传播到浣熊国的其他地方还要多久。
Raccoons don't teach each other these things, but it's called social learning, and even most monkeys don't do that. And so it's not like this innovation is going to spread across the city. Susanne McDonald doesn't think most raccoons in Toronto currently have what it takes to get into the new green compost bins, that perfect combination of strength, intelligence, and determination. Amy just happened to encounter an extra gifted one. We call her the genius raccoon because I think it's amazing that she did it.
浣熊不会互相教这些东西，但这被称为社会学习，甚至大多数猴子都不会这样做。所以这种创新不会在整个城市蔓延开来。苏珊·麦克唐纳认为，多伦多的大多数浣熊目前还不具备打开新绿色厨余垃圾桶的条件，也就是力量、智力和决心的完美结合。艾米只是恰好遇到了一只格外有天赋的浣熊。我们叫它天才浣熊，因为我觉得它做到了这一点太了不起了。
Suzanne finally finished her dead raccoon study, and Toronto's favorite frenemy is as fat as ever. She thinks that's because even though most of them can't get into the compost, they've moved on to a different solution. The good old-fashioned garbage. Our raccoons are not starving to death, that's for sure. But she doesn't rule out that in a far off future, we might end up creating an uber raccoon,
苏珊终于完成了她的死浣熊研究，多伦多最喜欢的“相爱相杀”的邻居依然像以前一样胖。她认为这是因为尽管它们大多数人打不开厨余垃圾桶，但它们已经转向了另一种解决方案。好那种老式的垃圾。我们的浣熊可没有饿死，那是肯定的。但她并不排除在遥远的未来，我们可能会创造出一只超级浣熊，
one like Amy's that can get into just about anything. She studied raccoons in cities, and they are, on the whole, smarter than their rural counterparts. Urban raccoons are constantly having new problems placed in front of them to solve, and they keep figuring them out. And Suzanne and Dennis both tell people that the green vents were never advertised as raccoon proof, only raccoon resistant. Nothing is raccoon proof, they say, which is a small concession that while the front of the line is holding for now, the war against raccoons continues.
就像艾米遇到那只一样，几乎什么都能打开。她研究过城市里的浣熊，总体而言，它们比农村同类更聪明。城市浣熊不断面临需要解决的新问题，而且它们一直在不断想出解决办法。苏珊和丹尼斯都告诉人们，绿色垃圾桶从未被宣传为“防浣熊”，而只是“抗浣熊”。他们说，没有什么东西是绝对防浣熊的，这是一个小小的妥协：虽然防线目前还能守住，但与浣熊的战争仍在继续。
More Raccoon News with our in-house Racco know that Kurt Coleset has a background in architecture. But if you also read the articles on our site, you probably also know that he's really into raccoons, too. So when these two interests intersect, like, say, a raccoon going viral on the internet for climbing up a downtown St. Paul office tower earlier this year. He was all over that story. Oh yeah, instantly. You know, the local news is there covering the story on the scene in Minnesota.
更多关于浣熊的新闻，由我们的内部浣熊专家库尔特·科尔斯特（Kurt Colstead）为您带来。你们可能知道库尔特有建筑学背景。但如果你也阅读我们网站上的文章，你大概也知道他同样对浣熊非常着迷。所以当这两个兴趣交织在一起时，比如今年早些时候，一只浣熊因为爬上圣保罗（St. Paul）市中心的一座办公大楼而在互联网上走红。他立刻就关注了这个故事。哦，对，瞬间就关注了。你知道，当地新闻当时正在明尼苏达州的现场报道这个故事。
But I'm out here, you know, researching the actual building that the recoon is climbing. And I got super into it. I was analyzing the facade and the materials. I started diagramming and then deconstructing the route that this recoon took to the top. And so if you want like a straight up Kennedy assassination style deconstruction
但我却在外面，研究这只浣熊正在攀爬的实际建筑。我超级投入。我一直在分析外墙和材料。我开始画图解，然后解构这只浣熊爬到顶部的路线。所以如果你想要一个直截了当的、肯尼迪遇刺风格的解构
of that whole saga, you can check out our website. But before we get too far off track, Kurt is here today with a story of a different famous raccoon from nearly a century ago. One that eventually resided in that particularly famous work of American architecture, the White House. Oh yes, history's not exactly full of famous records,
关于整个事件的分析，你可以查看我们的网站。但在我们偏离主题太远之前，库尔特今天要给我们讲一个关于近一个世纪前另一只著名浣熊的故事。那只浣熊最终住进了那座非常著名的美国建筑——白宫。哦，是的，历史上并不全是著名的浣熊，
but there's this one in particular that really stands out, especially around Thanksgiving. Her name was Rebecca, and in 1926, she was sent to President Calvin Coolidge as a gift from a constituent in Mississippi. But this record wasn't meant to be a pet. The idea was that actually that should be served up as part of the holiday feast.
但特别有这么一只非常引人注目，尤其是在感恩节前后。它的名字叫丽贝卡（Rebecca），1926年，它作为密西西比州选民的礼物被送给了卡尔文·柯立芝（Calvin Coolidge）总统。但这只浣熊并不是为了当宠物。当时的想法其实是把它作为节日大餐的一部分端上餐桌。
Which is not the most traditional Thanksgiving meal. Oh no, I mean not today at least, but a century ago, wild animals were much more common to see on, you know, dinner plates, meals with duck or turtle or possum were pretty typical. And in some cases, there were even regional delicacies. And then also, you know, sending animals as food to the White House for the holidays was a pretty popular tradition. So the president getting sent a raccoon wasn't maybe not that odd, but him keeping him as a pet was out of the ordinary. Right, I mean, that's a little bit more unusual when we think about presidents and Thanksgiving. We usually think of that turkey pardoning tradition.
这可不是最传统的感恩节大餐。哦，不，我是说至少现在不是，但在一个世纪前，野味在餐桌上要常见得多，吃鸭子、海龟或负鼠的饭菜是相当普遍的。在某些情况下，甚至还有地方特色菜。而且当时，把动物作为食物送给白宫过节也是一个相当流行的传统。所以总统获赠一只浣熊可能并不那么奇怪，但他把它当宠物养就非同寻常了。对，我的意思是，当我们想到历任总统和感恩节时，这有点不同寻常。我们通常会想到传统的赦免火鸡仪式。
And that's about it. But for Coolidge, it wasn't that weird. He and his wife had tons of pets. They had cats and dogs and birds, of course, but also these really exotic ones. Over the years, they got wallabies and a pair, a pair of wine cubs, even a pygmy hippo. Most of these, as gifts, often from foreign dignitaries
也就仅此而已了。但对柯立芝来说，这并不算奇怪。他和他的妻子养了成吨的宠物。他们有猫、狗、鸟，当然，还有这些非常异国情调的动物。这些年来，他们养过沙袋鼠、一对小熊，甚至还有一只侏儒河马。其中大多数都是礼物，通常来自外国政要，
who knew that the Coolidgeages were really into weird animals. But I'm still having a hard time picturing like a pigme hippo running around the White House though. Right. Well, some of them they, you know, re-gifted to zoos that could actually take care of them. But the coolages did keep a lot of them as pets and they formed this kind of weird White House menagerie, or as one reporter called it, the Pennsylvania Avenue Zoo. And so what about Rebecca, though, record? Well, she became part of the first family, essentially. Grace, the first lady, would walk her around on a leash during the day.
他们知道柯立芝夫妇非常喜欢奇奇怪怪的动物。但我还是很难想象一只侏儒河马在白宫里跑来跑去的画面。对。好吧，其中一些他们转送给了能真正照顾它们的动物园。但柯立芝夫妇确实把很多动物当宠物养着，它们形成了这种奇怪的白宫动物园，或者正如一位记者所说的那样，宾夕法尼亚大道动物园。那么丽贝卡这只浣熊呢？嗯，它基本上成了第一家庭的一员。第一夫人格蕾丝（Grace）白天会用皮带牵着它到处遛。
And then at night, she'd curl up with Calvin on his lap, next to the fireplace. That sounds like a pretty good pet. Well, yeah, I mean, that's one side of it. The other side is that she was still a wild animal and she became kind of infamous for, you know, chewing her way out of her enclosures and she'd wriggle out of the collars they put on her and she'd claw up the furniture in the White House. There's these stories of the Secret Service having to chase her
到了晚上，它会蜷缩在卡尔文的膝盖上，紧挨着壁炉。听起来是个相当不错的宠物。嗯，对，我的意思是，这是一方面。另一方面是它依然是一只野生动物，而且它因为从围栏里啃出一条路而变得“臭名昭著”，它会扭动着挣脱套在它身上的项圈，还会在白宫的家具上乱抓。有这样的一些故事，特勤局不得不追着它
around while she runs up trees and yeah, so she was a bit of a handful too, but, you know, she got to hang out in the White House sometimes. And the rest of the time she got this little wooden house that they put up for her on the South Fawn. So she's a little bit of a household, but she seems to have a pretty sweet life Rebecca the record. Yeah, she did. And she lived with the Coolages for a while and then the first couple handed her off to a zoo. And there were rumors at the time that maybe Rebecca bit Kelvin because one day he came out with a bandage on his hand. But Grace later wrote very fondly of this White House raccoon. According to her, Rebecca, quote,
到处跑，而它则爬上树，是的，所以它也有点难管教，但你知道，它有时能在白宫里闲逛。其余的时间，它住在他们在南草坪为它搭建的小木屋里。所以它有点像个家养宠物，但丽贝卡这只浣熊似乎过着相当甜蜜的生活。是的，它确实如此。它和柯立芝夫妇生活了一段时间，后来第一夫妇把它交给了动物园。当时有传言说，也许丽贝卡咬了卡尔文，因为有一天他手上缠着绷带出来。但格蕾丝后来非常深情地写到了这只白宫浣熊。据她回忆，丽贝卡，引述如下：
enjoyed nothing better than being placed in a bathtub with a little water in it and given a cake of soap with which to play. In this fashion, she would amuse herself for it hour or more. Wow. So obviously, if Nine-Eye PI. fans have any more raccoon stories, they should, you know, at you on Twitter, at Erkholstead. Yeah, definitely.
“最喜欢的事莫过于被放进放了少许水的浴缸里，并给它一块肥皂用来玩耍。用这种方式，它自己就能玩上一个多小时甚至更久。”哇。所以很明显，如果“99%无形”的听众还有更多浣熊的故事，他们应该在推特上@你，@Erkholstead。是的，绝对的。
Definitely. But they're already, they already do that. So you can add to the, you can add to the pile. Oh, yeah. Meanwhile, if you want to see some really lovely pictures of the first Lady Grace Coolidge and her raccoon friend, Rebecca, they up on the website at 99pi.org. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week By Our Senior Producer, Katie Mangle, based on Amy Dempsey's epic raccoon story
绝对的。但他们已经在这么做了。所以你可以把你的故事加到这堆成山的爆料里。哦，是的。同时，如果你想看一些第一夫人格蕾丝·柯立芝和她的浣熊朋友丽贝卡非常可爱的照片，它们已经发布在我们的网站 99pi.org 上了。“99%无形”本周由我们的高级制作人凯蒂·曼格尔（Katie Mangle）制作，故事取材于艾米·邓普西在《多伦多星报》上发表的史诗级浣熊故事。
from the Toronto Star. You should really read the whole story. It's great. We'll link on the website. Mix and Tech Production By Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Rial. This episode is dedicated to Kurt Colstead who enjoys nothing better than being placed in a bathtub with a little water in it and giving a cake of soap with which to play. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Trollman, Emmett Fitzgerald Vivian
你真的应该通读整个故事。非常棒。我们会在网站上提供链接。混音与技术制作由谢里·费尤塞夫（Sheree Fusef）完成，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作。本集献给库尔特·科尔斯特，他最喜欢的事莫过于被放进放了少许水的浴缸里，并给它一块肥皂用来玩耍。团队的其他成员还有高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、艾弗里·特罗尔曼（Avery Truelman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·李（Vivian Lee）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、特兰·马扎（Terran Mazza），以及我罗曼·马斯（Roman Morris）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街（Radio Row）。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Lee, Joe Rosenberg, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Morris. We are a project of 91.7K ALW inL-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Lee、Joe Rosenberg、Terran Mazza，以及我 Roman Morris。我们是旧金山 91.7K ALW inL-W 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的 Radio Row。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。